j'ai grandi dans l'une de ces banlieues
que l'on décrit aujourd'hui comme des
territoires perdus de la république la
naissance dans les quartiers n'accorde
pas de diplôme de compétence
mais un jour j'en ai eu assez d'entendre
les beaux quartiers de paris m'expliquer
ce qui se passait dans la banlieue
populaire
[Musique]
j'essaie de décrire ce que je vis depuis
maintenant quelques années en tant
qu'élu ces quartiers là puisque je suis
en ses murs de sarcelles et député de la
8e circonscription val d'oise dans
lesquelles ils à garges les gonesse
sarcelles villiers le bel
et pas un peu plus loin il y à aussi
goussainville donc juge explique comment
un seul homme de réseaux liées à l'islam
radical sont en train de s'implanter et
que l'avènement de l'islam politique est
une réalité de ces territoires
[Musique]
les émirats la république c'est un livre
fait par un élu que je suis qui est dans
ces territoires depuis longtemps et
qu'ils voient comment l'islam politique
et l'islam radical est en train de
s'implanter d'essayer de prendre le
pouvoir
ma thèse c'est que si on prend pas garde
eh bien la france en subira les
conséquences et les premières victimes
de ceux là seront les musulmans de
france donc c'est une manière pour moi
d'alerté tout le monde d'essayer les
vieilles les consciences pour faire en
sorte qu'il y ait un sursaut une
réaction
[Musique]
moi je commence à y penser vraiment en
juillet 2014 dans ce cas une
manifestation pro-palestinienne à
sarcelles il a fini au crime en revue
c'était le déclic je me suis dit
la ville où j'ai grandi n'est plus la
même il se passe des choses j'essaie de
comprendre d'analyser et après j'ai
ressenti le besoin de l'écrire pour les
tribunes écoutez il ya bien sûr le
houellebecq sur la manière dont il avait
vu l'évolution des choses qui avaient
des quand même un peu fait prendre
conscience sur deux personnes et puis
elle est l'oeuvre de chercheurs qui ont
travaillé sur 6 juin et je trouvais
intéressant à la lecture de ses oeuvres
de dire mais peut-être aussi manque
l'oeuvre de quelqu'un qui peut témoigner
concrètement que ce qui est dit à la fin
d'un rêve de houellebecq nos six
chercheurs correspond à la réalité et
donc c'est pour ça que j'ai écrit ce
livre je m'attaque et vie dénonce les
réseaux de l'islam politique et 10,1 me
radical que je n'attaque pas du tout les
musulmans de france au contraire
ce livre est plutôt un plaidoyer pour
les musulmans de france
[Musique]